a giant space Ark fires its fusion
rockets inside the ship are thousands of
human volunteers there on a one-way
mission to colonize a distant planet
one day we will have to make this
journey it's inevitable that we go off
planet I think we're gonna have to do it
to survive as a species the Ark's first
target is the closest star system to the
Sun Alpha Centauri and the journey will
be long around 40 years keeping the crew
fit and healthy is imperative but it
won't be easy a lot of things happen to
the human body when you go into space
and the moment you become weightless you
instantly get kind of a full headed
feeling you get dizzy that can make you
feel nauseous
Leroy Chiao spent six months on the
International Space Station long enough
to experience the damaging effects of
zero gravity your bones aren't feeling
any impact so your body decides it
doesn't need bones anymore and it'll
begin to demineralize your bones and
then your muscles through disuse of
course they'll naturally atrophy very
quickly the human body evolved to live
with Earth's gravity without it bones
lose two percent of their mass for every
month spent in space the cardiovascular
system suffers two body fluids pool
heart rates and blood pressure rise
resistance training helps reduce the
symptoms we're scheduled for two hours
of exercise a day on the Space Station's
to keep our cardiovascular system fed to
keep our muscles in our bones fit
exercising can hold off the dangerous
wasting process
but a 42 year journey to Alpha Centauri
without gravity would be fatal
obviously we need a permanent solution
to weightlessness there's nothing to
prevent us in the near future from
creating artificial gravity
the answer is centrifugal force
it's the force that sticks daredevil
bikers to vertical walls and keeps
thrill-seekers glued to their seats in
theme parks rotation produces this
outward force and creating it in a
spaceship would be relatively simple
by rotating a space capsule it means
that the astronauts inside will
experience artificial gravity spinning
the living quarters at just the right
speed will hold off bone and muscle
wasting but as they journey deep into
space low gravity is the least of the
dangers our pioneers will face